de 300 à 450 euros pour une taille
moyenne de 19 mètres carrés un prix une
taille attractif voilà l'offre de la
nouvelle résidence étudiante situé à la
verrière à une centaine de mètres de la
gare sncf
ouvert depuis la fin août les 179
studios sont déjà tous occupés au début
ça a commencé très bien parce qu on a eu
beaucoup de demandes
on est déjà complet et
la demande ça se fait par internet donc
on a une grande liste d'attentes et je
pense par rapport aux prix c'est un
avantage parce que vous avez de 300
euros à 450
elle a 17 ans originaire de normandie
s'est installé il ya quelques jours dans
sa chambre vivre en résidence c'est
également pour l occasion de rencontrer
d'autres étudiants et d'éviter le blues
de la rentrée c'est pas mal parce que
bell ne voyez pas très cher
et tout est compris à voir les tristes
et donc et fario même internet donc c
est pratique pour faire des recherches
des trucs comme ça et en plus c'est bien
parce que je suis pas tout seul parce
que je me retrouve un peu isolée donc
comme ça je peux je peux rencontrer des
gens de ma résidence enfants tous via
lui il ya que des étudiants donc c'est
sympa
deux salles communes une laverie un
parking d'un garage à vélos la nouvelle
résidence étudiante de la verrière
dispose de nombreux services plus aucun
logement n'est disponible pour cette
année scolaire